ots pessoal de quem fala é o lugar que
seja muito bem vindo a mostrar jequié
cnet o gênio da internet é que o fluxo
consegue ganhar tudo o que posso estou
pensado um consegue descobrir quem é
você mãe vai jogar amanhã equipe eu vou
descobrir tudo é que o curso está já a
pensar pra começar este banho vou
começar a pensar em quem em que aí
seu personagem é real assim eu acho que
sim mas seu personagem faz filmes sobre
game por conta no mar dois e eu já vai
direto ao assunto o seu personagem é
meio gordinho
seu personagem é do velho oeste eu sei
que eu sou um caubói
seu personagem é um elfo também não o
seu personagem faz parte de um single it
flui palavra esta não se quer um
substituto por isso não satisfaz para
torna-se o personagem já vai ao brasil
não acho que estava eu quero o seu
personagem jogava com óculos assim o seu
personagem e barbudo não o personagem já
fiz uma série sobre o cta não o
impressionou roda jean o seu personagem
o buchicho no não o seu personagem é um
mordomo também não suportassem tem bafo
seu tem bafo que não se o personagem
principal da série ela manteria também
no homem o seu personagem faz parte do
mundo músico total eu nem sei o que é
isso o seu personagem tem um canal do
tour é a hora que está é pergunta que eu
mais temia pela partida que já vai ver a
neve se o personagem gasta tempo com
vampiros também não gosta de vampiros e
ainda por cima que o lapso pão sangue
mas de homens
seu personagem faz parte do jogo
fascinante é fredes não faz parte mas
que estavam sem personagem faz vídeos do
tour sem já disse que sim sobre imagem
vivem em portugal e vai ganhar vai
ganhar na alemanha deutsche bank também
era um caso fácil né perguntou se eu
tinha um canal suas dívidas do tesouro
tinha a consciência gordo obviamente que
vai rodar aqui né mesmo
a companhia já não vamos tentar outro
personagem desta vez de escolher uma
personagem de bull uma personagem
fascinante freire favorito que é o fox e
vamos lá ver se consegue um fox e um
personagem no youtube porque começou com
esta pergunta não é se é português
também não se personagem é real também
não seu personagem tem cabelo eu tenho
pela em todo lado amigos em
seu personagem lutas em seu personagem
faz parte um anime animação japonesa na
o seu personagem de um filme e leve um
jogo mas tecnicamente jogo tem que sim
não se o personagem é de um jogo ora
aqui está o que eu queria era a partida
que já vai dar a volta ao cérebro já não
vai comer a cabeça imagina que é a
substância que faz parte do jogo fugindo
mas também não se o personagem do jogo
minecraft na o seu personagem luta
usando uma espada também não usam dez
piratas o personagem luta com armas de
fogo no bairro é um amigo já disse que
usou dez piratas o personagem é uma
mulher também eu já disse que a
operadora tokyo para sua personagem é um
personagem principal do trabalho em que
ela aparece eu não é o principal o
principal eu acho que o fred neves o
personagem e dubai
ora aqui está uma pergunta que pode
exigir nada que alguma polêmica porque
busco foxy eu não sei se o início e uns
15 ajudado ou não mas devo dizer que não
sei se o personagem tem cabelos pretos
não eu tenho cabelo quem cuida nem mais
substância que faz parte da rota 2
também não se está a gente tem cabelos
brancos não só quando for velho né seu
personagem em poleiros é eu tenho poder
de sustar as pessoas não vou dizer que o
seu estágio faz parte do jogo clash of
clãs também não é só não vai definir não
só não pergunta e 21 e até agora ainda
não o seu personagem um estudante também
não eu faço empregável talento a
trabalhar numa pizzaria postagem de
pedra branca também né o amigo é uma
foto em que se aposenta o seu personagem
faz parte um jogo de terror e ora aqui
está seu personagem usa um tapa-olho já
descobriu me propunha que o chinês que
os piratas usam lá o que estava faltando
uma pala quintal chance paula não é de
batatas paula não é mesmo paulo
vamos dizer que sim e ela que já vai
disponível já tá
bob sido paga só família disse fred em
sua opinião o filme mas não como é que o
conselho só que vamos pensar numa mais
difícil
eu vou tentar uma coisa tão estúpida que
é a minha mãe não estivesse não consegue
acompanhar a minha mãe a sério sua
parceira a cara dela leisure mil euros
vai pra rua tudo no e enfim uma prévia
do seu personagem faz vídeos sobre
gauchão ela só faz comida em casa seu
personagem é real é o seu personagem
mora no seu país sim à memória a minha
casa né seu personagem já no feminino
sem o seu estádio e ficou famoso graças
à internet novo personagem famoso novo
personagem amamentou voz sequer poderia
amamentar voz e o pai e os seus poderes
sim não vai enviar mesmo ainda não se o
personagem faz partos drec o sonho o
sonho que é um filme não não faz parte
nada ela só tem que cedeu o seu
personagem de origem européia sim
portugal faz para ter o cumprimento que
o site delfi a escola você já se
apaixonou pelo seu personagem não não
não claramente não é um amor diferente
né não é que o amor tipo uau
sua mãe não como é que eu tenho a minha
mãe cuidou mas sabe que eu sou agora
sabe jóias apoio aqui eu vou pensar num
personagem de um filme que é um dos meus
filmes favoritos com o véu sim é que um
leque matam e monstro de coisas o
personagem faz vídeos sobre jogos no o
seu personagem é real tecnicamente o
ator é real mas o ver nelsinho em si não
porque eu faço um filme não sai não é
real não é um filme não é um não ator é
um personagem o seu estágio bem eu matar
monstros e e vampiros maus por isso eu
acho que é o seu personagem de um jogo
no seu personagem do gênero feminino
também não sempre imagem luta sim muitos
com armas o seu estágio faz parte um
anime animação japonesa não se o
personagem faz parte um desanimado anel
sempre estaremos usando uma espada
eu acho que nos espadas o nome do seu
personagem preço do título de um filme
sim o seu personagem cunha reporta verá
o seu personagem usa uma máscara não se
imagina um ser humano sem o seu
personagem usa chapéu sim o seu
personagem tem ensaios ou seja mas tenta
o seu personagem fez parte do jackson
five eu nem sequer jaxa ela assina um
lado michael jackson há o que os campo
imaginem o nelsinho é cantar o seu
personagem é um trato grande cairo que
isso um trambiqueiro eu acho um
trambiqueiro deve ser a que eu acho que
é super sexy é prostituta também né
amigo sei que o tempo é difícil mas seu
personagem mal eu já disse que levou
ouvir um não é mau né mec na internet já
tás a falar do tratado ficar confuso o
personagem apareceu na tv quando era
pequeno não eu fiz o filme como é grande
né o seu personagem o indiana jones
também não se o personagem é um policial
o detido não é um caçador de vampiros
seu personagem um luta contra o monstro
sim o seu personagem gasta tempo com
vampiros agora
ai ai que vai ganhar eu vou a bruxa hoje
eu guardo como é calçado essas coisas -
até poderia pensar no morcego do wanel
sim aquilo ia atrás dele descobrir como
cego eu fazia isso na foto vamos pensar
numa melhor já saiu o trio corda para
puxar eu vou pensar nos azuis o que é
que o quadro do rei leão sabem que o
pássaro azul é muito improvável que eu
consiga encontrar um espaço porque eu
nem sequer é uma personagem principal é
um forte impacto analisou seu personagem
é o youtube é não faz vezes o estágio é
uma mulher também não se o personagem
mora em seu país não se o personagem é
real também não anda animada o seu
personagem tem cabelos campinas que pode
ser campeão também mas não o seu
personagem tem a forma de um animal é
nesta pergunta vai direto ao assunto meu
clube é possível o seu personagem usa um
tapa-olho não não é o foco sempre imagem
faz parte do jogo de terror também não
sobre estágios roupas azuis a roupa não
sempre está em saber falar sim seu
personagem de um filme mas sim o seu
personagem anda sobre duas pernas sim e
vai descobrir - não vai descobrir -
substância é um governo não se esvaziem
tem bico é uma escuridão
o substrato é um pinguim não esse
personagem é sua e sim próprio trabalho
descobrir o seu personagem é ter fins
nem sim o seu personagem entrou em
piratas das caraíbas não é o fim ou não
da não pode ser menor pois pra vocês têm
um estado de espírito de um dos
comentários os personagens que vocês
querem que o tempo de ganhar aqui não eu
não acreditasse nós queremos ver se ele
é mesmo um gênio internet torna um digo
coisas difíceis é difícil e é isso conto
com vocês aqui do brito fiquem bem até a
próxima